in the meantime one of the teachers
union says they have reached a contract
agreement with the school district 8
news now reporter joe muller joins us to
explain what this all means joe
both of the parties say this is a step
in the right direction these contracts
have been months in the making and
they'll be going through the last
through june of 2023.
there are two tentative agreements the
first is the teachers union there will
be a three percent increase in salary
and step increases after that the union
executive director john villardita says
the backlog of insurance claims will be
paid by june of 2022. in terms of any
educator facing any kind of collections
for claims or whatnot the trust has
acquired a consumer advocate
law firm to help process that to make
sure that no educator has to go through
that as for the association of school
administrators agreement salaries are
raised by 3 percent in the first year
and the district will increase health
insurance contribution by 5 percent
next the board will review these
tentative agreements on thursday
reporting live outside of ccsd
headquarters joe mohler live local now